6 15 on your wednesday morning our look
at the city's most dangerous
intersections continues you know we've
talked about driver and pedestrian
behavior as contributing factors at
charleston and rainbow sahara and
decatur and while that can be true
anywhere
sometimes the intersection itself is a
factor
three things can lead to confusion here
at boulder highway and nellis
first of all boulder highway is at an
angle
second it's actually part of a triangle
with boulder highway nellis and flamingo
and the third element thrown into the
mix pedestrians oftentimes on motorized
scooters aaron breen the director of the
road equity alliance i call that
intersection the trifecta of doom
because it is so awful you have signals
that are only timed for pedestrians to
get half across the street and a lot of
them don't realize that
so they push the button they wait for
the green
and they think to themselves oh no i
have time i push the button so they keep
walking when they were supposed to wait
in the middle
and then you have traffic that
that stop in the middle of the
intersection might actually be new
information for pedestrians there as for
aaron's comment about the intersection
being awful she quickly pointed out that
that entire area is on the regional
transportation commission's
reconfiguration drawing board part of
the larger reimagine boulder highway
project but in terms of dangerous
intersections right now that trifecta of
doom deserves caution for drivers and
pedestrians flamingo nellis boulder
highway tomorrow we're going to be
staying in the southeast an intersection
where crazy raised its ugly head just as
it can anywhere we're going to take you
there i think we all have stories about
seeing crazy drivers we just had that
story the other day about another
possible hundred mile an hour driver
involved in that crash around saharan
maryland parkway we've got to get our
heads around this problem and do
something about it